the figures for week 52 that's the last
week of the year for covert and flu
seems to suggest that those covert and
flu numbers are down on that previous
week week 51. now this could mean that
we've passed the peak of infections for
covid and flu but it's more likely
because of a blip because of Christmas
and that's what the UK HSA are warning
us when we look at these figures to to
look at them in context although the
figures show a slight decline on the
previous week they are still high but
it's more likely because people are
although because of Christmas you're
mixing with larger groups you have
family get-togethers Etc but you're not
actually mixing in larger numbers
as far as infections are concerned
you're not taking the train or the bus
to work and you're not meeting outside
of work etc etc and fewer people might
have been testing so they're urging
caution when you look at these figures
but certainly the indicators are for
covert and flu that's week 52 that's the
last week of the year covert and flu
cases were down the infections are down
on the previous week that's week 51 and
we've also had the numbers published by
the ons that's the office for National
statistics they're giving us
an overview of the number of people who
excess deaths a number of people who've
died over and Beyond
um
any given year why people are dying
outside any given setting let me go
through those numbers with you the they
show an increase of
um on previous years 14 530 people died
in England and Wales in the week to the
23rd of December that's the highest
amount during any week last year and
when we compare that to averages from
previous years it means nearly two and a
half thousand more people died than
expected so that's for the one week
alone but over the past six months the
total number of excess deaths is over 30
000 in England and Wales there have been
exactly eight thousand deaths due to
covid in that period And if we exclude
those from the total it means there's
been an extra 22 040 deaths not caused
by covert in the past six months alone
that's equivalent to
848 a week remember too Sergio we have
that warning from the Royal College of
emergency medicine that these excess
death figures which are a really good
indicator of of uh what's happening with
the state of the nation in terms of what
we would expect to see in any given year
or in any given period with surges and
flu and covert and everything else how
many people are dying beyond that period
and we had the warning from the Royal
College of emergency medicine that they
were suggesting that up to 500 people a
week were dying more than they should
have been because of the NHS pressures
and that's been disputed by the
government and by the NHS saying that it
doesn't think up to 500 more people have
died because of those pressures but
that's certainly what the Royal College
of emergency medicine is telling us but
these figures from the ons suggesting
that we have seen a large increase in
the number of excess deaths than we
would expect to see according to the
yearly averages